Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Phil from California. Phil,
you're on the air.
Speaker 5:
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Hi, David.
I had a question about propaganda in general.
And it seems like with with propaganda, it seems
to have an origin where there's a voluntary actor
who kind of promulgates the initial idea of
propaganda and disperses it. But at what point
does the public propaganda become like a feedback
loop and people that are propagating it also are
consuming it and falling for it?
Speaker 1: Oh, it happens very
quickly. Oh sorry, go ahead. Yeah.
Speaker 5: I was going to just say,
for example, it seems like Putin may have fallen
for his own propaganda with his initial attack on
the Ukraine and how poorly his army performed
was probably partially to believe in his own
propaganda about liberating Ukraine.
And he would be welcomed with open arms.
Speaker 1: I'm not sure about that. I don't I
don't think Putin was that naive, but I think
your principle is very much there. I see it
much more like in the current Republican Party,
where I see it the other way, where it's sort of
the people that fell for the Trump is really the
winner. Propaganda end up spreading it and then
they end up believing it because people they've
convinced start repeating it themselves.
So that's the feedback loop that I've seen.
I don't know that the Putin example, I don't
know if I don't know how sure I am of the Putin
example, but your idea is absolutely spot on.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you very
much for the call. Nice, concise call there